pour s'installer plus facilement en
chine certaines entreprises participent
aux efforts de coopération voici
l'exemple de wuhan qu'on appelle parfois
la ville des français il y à un lycée
français une université est un hôpital
reportage pascal golomer sylvain
guillaume qu'on peut voir des visages
souriant nombre bienvenue en cours de
latin un professeur un élève très qui
dit à tous les classes surchargées ici
on ne connaît pas l'école française de
houran accueille 80 élèves de la
maternelle à la première peugeot citroën
est la note pour les familles de ses
employés français qui travaillent dans
l'usiné du groupe tout proche
les expatriés de la quinzaine
d'entreprises françaises présentes dans
la ville et y ont aussi accès un petit
coin de france au bord du lot c'est
qu'on vient pas en chine pour rester
entre en france elle entre donc c'est
vrai que c'est une chance et c'est
beaucoup plus facile là avec ces
conditions de vie ne faut pas hésiter à
sortir et c'est tout à fait possible à
moral est assez comme une grande villa
une immense agglomération en effet près
de 8 millions d'habitants dans laquelle
et quelques dizaines de résidents
français ne pèse pas lourd pourtant
houran est l'une des villes les plus
francophiles de chine surtout grâce à
son université
c'est celle qui envoie le plus
d'étudiants en france près de 307 et le
succès des cours de français va
grandissant ces élèves qui ont déjà et
une formation scientifique et si les
apprennent comme complément la langue
française alors ils sont très très
apprécié et très recherchée maintenant
mais les plus francophile et francophone
c'est à l'hôpital universitaire qu'on
les trouve on m'a donné le plein pouvoir
j'ai construit à partir des murs ici
grands blocs opératoires à 31 ans zhao
yan un français d'origine chinoise a
monté de toutes pièces le tout nouveau
service des urgences en s'inspirant de
celui de la pitié salpêtrière où il
travaillait auparavant jusqu'à traduire
en français
toutes les inscriptions aux mules d'un
immigré est passé au statut de médecin
et c'est pour ça c'est la france pour
moi je dirai jamais mes ancêtres les
gaulois parce que je sais qui mais en
700 chinois que j'essaye chinois je suis
français et marquer cet anneau
ronchinois et en français enfin s'est
affiché ce que je ressens un clin d'oeil
mais c'est aussi le symbole d'une
coopération médicale de plus en plus
étroite entre orane la francophile et
les hôpitaux français
[Musique]